His name is Robert Lloyd Schellenberg.
A Canadian national in Chinese custody since
20-14.
Originally he had been sentenced to 15 years
in prison for masterminding a drug smuggling
plot, a charge he continues to deny.
But in a surprise move, an appeals court allowed
Chinese prosecutors to retry him.
The result...
The defendant is guilty of smuggling drugs
and is sentenced to death.
All of his personal assets will be confiscated.
Canada's embassy has urged its citizens to
be cautious when traveling to China.
And the Prime Minister has also expressed
his misgivings.
But I will say it is of extreme concern to
us as a government as it should be to all
our international friends and allies that
China has chosen to begin to arbitrarily apply
death penalty in cases facing - as in this
case - facing a Canadian.
The verdict represents a new escalation in
a diplomatic spat between Beijing and Ottawa.
Observers have linked Schellenberg's fresh
conviction to Canada's arrest of this women
- Meng Wanzhou.
She's a senior executive at telecommunications
giant Huawei and the daughter of its founder.
She's accused of helping the company bypass
US sanctions and American authorites are seeking
her extradition.
Schellenberg's retrail was boxed through just
weeks afer Wanzhou was taken into custody.
And it now seems her fate, as well as that
of Schellenberg and two other Canadians in
Chinese custody might not be decided in a
court of law but rather on the international
stage.